hi everyone sal khan here from khan
academy welcome to the homeroom live
stream we've had a little bit of a
hiatus so it's good to see all of y'all
again we have a really exciting guest
today neil kashkari who is the president
of the federal reserve bank of
minneapolis so we're going to be able to
talk a lot about the economy and the
federal reserve and everything that's
going on but before we jump into that i
will give a couple of my standard
reminders first of all a reminder that
khan academy is a not-for-profit and we
can only exist through donations from
folks like yourself if you're in a
position to do so so please think about
going to khan academy.org donate and
donations of all size make a huge huge
difference i also want to give a special
shout out to several organizations that
have stepped up especially during covid
when they realized that khan academy uh
was
being even more leaned on
and we were running at a deficit we're
continuing to run a deficit into 2021
but special thanks to bank of america
att google.org novartis fastly and
general motors for stepping up in a big
way to ensure that we could continue to
serve
tens of millions of learners around the
world through the crisis and beyond and
then the last reminder is that you can
get a version of this live stream
in podcast format wherever you get your
podcast at homeroom without the podcast
so with that i'm really excited to
introduce neil kashkari neil
thanks for joining
thanks for having me sal it's great to
be with you
so i i've been dying to have this
conversation since we you know you you
first came on my radar obviously uh you
you during uh the the 2010 financial
crisis you were very involved there and
then you've had a really fascinating um
uh i guess career where where now you're
the president of the federal reserve
bank of minneapolis so let's start in
the present maybe a good place to start
is what
you know peop i think people have most
people have a general idea that there's
something called the federal reserve it
affects things like monetary policy and
interest rates and then you have these
regional banks of which you're a
president of one of them how does all of
this work what is the overall charter of
the federal reserve and what is kind of
the role of the of the regional banks
well thanks for starting ourselves so in
1913 congress created the federal
reserve system which is the nation's
central bank and very simply our job
dated to move interest rates up and down
to try to manage the ups and downs of
the us economy but congress something
unique in 1913 they said they don't want
the central bank simply housed in
washington dc in the capital they wanted
distributed around the country so they
created 12 independent federal reserve
banks the ninth of which is the
minneapolis fed
so our job is to cover this region
minnesota north and south dakota montana
part of michigan and part of wisconsin
and the 12th federal reserve bank is the
federal reserve bank of san francisco
which covers a huge area that wasn't
very populated in 1913 but today it's
really populated the whole western third
of the united states is effectively
covered by the san francisco fed
so our jobs are we do a bunch of things
we regulate banks we provide cash so if
you go to the atm you need to take out
100
that cash would have started out in a
federal reserve bank but we also
understand what's happening in the
economy and participate in the process
where we set interest rates for the
nation to try to achieve this economy
that is growing not overheating but also
not limping along
and and for anyone who's curious we have
actually many khan academy videos on
exactly the mechanism by how the federal
reserve can insert money and affect
interest rates it's a little bit complex
but definitely understandable so i
encourage people to check that out if
you're really if you're really curious
about that and
you know neil what what is you know on a
day-to-day basis what are kind of the
types of questions that you think about
uh and are kind of within your your
charter or you're thinking about right
now
well right now i mean and this is we
have two goals fundamental goals that
congress has given us to achieve that
stable economy one is low inflation that
we define as two percent inflation and
one is maximum employment as many
americans as possible are working and
participating in our economy and we
normally think these two goals are
intentioned and we're trading them off
of each other so if the economy is
really strong and businesses have to
compete to find workers the unemployment
rate will go down wages will go up and
that'll lead to inflation and then we'll
have to raise interest rates to level
that off
well so that's where a lot of our time
is focused is are we at maximum
employment what's happening in the
economy is their spare capacity now with
the pandemic you know before the
pandemic hit the unemployment rate in
america was quite low at around three
and a half percent but then the pandemic
hit and millions of americans lost their
jobs so the past year my job has been
different for the past year i've spent a
lot of time
talking to the best health experts in
the country to understand where is the
virus likely going
how long is this crisis going to endure
and then what does that mean for our
economic recovery so we can achieve
maximum employment and put americans
back to work
and what do you think are the levers at
the federal reserve's uh
what are the levers at y'all's disposal
you know there's this notion of lowering
interest rates as much as possible and
you know some of the mechanics of that
is essentially you're able to increase
the aggregate federal reserve balance
sheet insert more cash and so
interest rates
can can come down
but it seems like you know right now
we're already getting close to the the
floor there
are there other levers that the federal
reserve can do or is it really more
dependent on
the federal government
to do more fiscal stimulus at this point
yeah great great question so we we are
doing a lot we're using our tools i
wouldn't say that they're fully maxed
out but we're using them aggressively
and by lowering interest rates we make
it cheaper for a family to get a
mortgage to buy a house or for a
business to get a loan to go build a
factory that's how we stimulate the
economy so our our foot on the floor
right now really trying to give a lot of
stimulus to get the economy moving again
and you're right so now the key really
is for fiscal policy makers for the
congress to continue to step up to
support the millions of americans who've
lost their jobs and their thousands and
thousands of small businesses
many have already shuttered but many are
teetering because their businesses have
been impacted by this and so this the
coba crisis is an example where monetary
policy and fiscal policy can complement
each other to support the american
people until we get the pandemic behind
us
and one question related to that that
i'm you know i've been having at dinner
parties and i don't know the right
answer to it i don't think there's a
clear answer
you know
all of the monetary policy and and the
the
the the monetary stimulus that's been
going in it makes all the sense in the
world to me for all the reasons you just
said you know a lot of especially in
service sector retail jobs travel
airlines they are suffering
if you can lower interest rates it can
stimulate some demand people can
continue to invest in certain areas they
can the cost of buying certain things
will go down et cetera et cetera but it
does seem like there's this divergence
you know people talked about the
k-shaped economic recovery where to some
degree those who do have access to
capital you know even people who own
houses when interest rates go down they
can refinance they benefit they you know
the buyers have more purchasing power so
the house price goes up they benefit uh
arguably uh you know companies might
benefit and and once again that might
have follow-on benefits for many many
other folks but you know if you if you
use the stock market i know the stock
market shouldn't necessarily be the high
fidelity indicator but if you use that
if you use other indicators it does look
like this this this
separation that's happened where uh
those who have some assets who have
access to kind of uh resources are are
doing better uh and and the the monetary
policy isn't able to necessarily reach
as much those who who don't have as many
resources
i i think that's very fair i think the
k-shape recovery is real you know the
tech sector is booming uh the companies
like in minnesota general mills is one
of our big companies they grew up
provide the food that's on the shelves
in our grocery stores because we've all
stopped going onto restaurants and i go
to the grocery store a lot more often
companies like general mills are doing
really well in this pandemic but then
you have the restaurants and you have
the airlines and you have the hotels and
so i think the k-shape recovery is real
and let's be clear low interest rates is
not going to do anything to help a
restaurant that is closed because of the
pandemic right if they can't have
customers come in because it's not safe
there's simply nothing that interest
rates are going to do to help them and
that's why we're doing whatever we can
to
give give the best analysis we have
encourage our friends in the congress or
in the executive branch to say provide
fiscal support to people who've been
laid off into those small businesses
where monetary policy
is not going to be is not going to be
very helpful and monetary policy is a
blunt instrument that affects the whole
economy at the same time there's no way
for us to target it to one sector or
another sector
and what's your view there i know you
know the federal reserve is
intentionally separate from the
government and it's it's intended to be
a kind of a non-political entity but
right now in washington you do have a
debate where it looks like the biden
administration wants to be more
aggressive on the stimulus while the
republican members of congress want to
be a little bit more conservative they
also want to do it but we're talking
about you know i think you know 600
billion versus you know well over a
trillion or two
does the federal reserve have a point of
view on that or are you allowed to have
a public point of view on that
you know i get asked about that from
elected representatives from my district
all the time and i always give them the
best advice i can
i think those kind of negotiations
generally between well should it be 1
trillion or 600 billion or 1.4 trillion
i think we try to stay out of that
because that really is about the
political process making those decisions
i think i i've been very vocal and i'll
continue to be vocal saying you know
the job market today in america is as
bad as the worst job market during the
financial crisis the headline
unemployment rate is 6.5 2.5 6.7 percent
the real unemployment rate is around 10
percent there's a lot of people given up
looking for work so my basic message is
we are nowhere close to having rebuilt
our economy and putting people back to
work and so whatever congress and the
administration choose to do i would
encourage them to focus on those
millions of americans that are still
suffering today still out of work they
need more assistance until we can get
this pandemic behind us
yeah and what you just highlighted i
think is a really important point
because a lot of folks don't realize
that you know the details of how things
like unemployment how they're calculated
uh really tell you a lot about things
because there's a world where people
could get laid off and as long as
they're continuing to look for work
they're included in the labor pool and
so they're counted in the unemployment
but then if they just give up at some
point say yeah you know what i'm just
not gonna find a job i'm just gonna like
you know live with my parents or
something else then they're not even
they're not even counted in the
unemployment so actually you could have
this this this dynamic uh but to your
point i guess you know the more stimulus
we can do the better how concerned if we
do very aggressive
stimulus because you know we talked
about earlier and this is kind of your
classical point of view is if you if the
federal government runs huge deficits in
order to provide stimulus um all while
interest rates are quite low that that
might create a lot of demand for a
limited pool of resources or capacity or
productivity which could lead to a lot
of inflation which is obviously related
to one of y'all's charter how how
worried are you all about that right now
i'll speak for myself i'm not worried
about it inflation has been running low
for 10 years before the pandemic and now
it's running even lower if we had a
little bit more inflation i think we
would consider that to be a success in
us achieving our goal of 2 inflation
here in europe but something really
curious happened in this pandemic
those of us who kept our jobs like you
like me like many of your viewers here
today
generally speaking we're saving more
money because we're not going out to
restaurants instead we're going to the
grocery store we're not taking vacations
and trips we're staying at home so the
savings rate has gone way up because
people who kept their jobs are doing
fine their incomes haven't been cut and
they're saving more money so the way the
macro economy works if you keep that
money in the bank it ends up flowing
back into the financial markets and that
money is actually available to finance
these increased government deficits so i
do think at some point you know we have
to get our fiscal house in order we have
to make tough choices as a country but
right now this is like we're at war and
this is in my view war time spending to
defeat the virus that enemy and to
support our fellow americans until we
can get through it so we have the
capacity to do it
and and i i want to encourage everyone
uh watching on youtube or facebook
please send your questions we're already
getting a lot of great questions and
i'll start with one
from smart bear on youtube asking how do
you think the economy will change in the
near future due to the covet 19 variants
and more and i'll extend that
you know do you think there's going to
be
let's hope a year from now we're back to
some normalcy do you think there's going
to be structural changes to the economy
because of what we're going through it
with covid
i think there are and i think that they
are hard to identify right now i mean
one example is we've all figured out you
figured this out sal a long time ago but
we all the rest of us figured out that
you can actually work remotely very
effectively in many industries and in
many cases not all but in many and so i
would expect that
the use of technology like this is going
to be permanently higher than it was
before the pandemic i don't know we have
1100 employees at our bank
uh all but 50 or 70 of them are working
remotely working from home
i expect the vast majority to come into
the bank but might our structures look a
little bit different to take advantage
of this technology and provide more
flexibility it's certainly possible
might we travel a little less for
conferences and do more of them
virtually or in a hybrid format
certainly so i think that likely
there'll be many changes that are
permanent that are positive that are
hard to identify exactly right now
yeah i actually even heard i agree with
a lot of that and i'm fascinated you
know even at khan academy we're thinking
about what's our what's the right use of
office space how much travel do we need
to do et cetera et cetera uh but you
know i i was entertained when i read
this was several months ago that uh
retailers are seeing a lot of sales of
of tops of formal tops and casual
bottoms so
finally the rest of the world is
starting to dress like i am i don't know
if you're wearing jogging pants below
the waist but i am right now so
you can't see it
[Laughter]
very very i won't make you i won't make
you validated but i i i said hello i'm
going to talk to the president of the
federal reserve bank of minneapolis i
have to put on a button shirt but i
still have my jogging pants on but yes
that might be another another another
structural another structural change you
know there's there's a question here
from youtube a chalk day and and i'll
ask the question i'll extend it a little
bit you know should the education system
teach banking at school and i'll accept
it should should there be more of an
emphasis on finance personal finance
uh accounting
you know a lot of people uh if you go
back to the financial crisis back in
2009 2010 people describe it to just
lack of financial literacy people
getting over their heads
where is there you know obviously at
khan academy we'll try to do what we can
but i'm curious your point of view on a
chalk day's question
absolutely i think a bigger investment
in financial literacy and just making
you know regardless of what your
profession is going to be
you're going to have to manage your own
personal finances and find a way to make
ends meet and figure out can i afford
this house or can i afford this car or
even this cell phone plan that i might
be interested in and the basics of
financial literacy i think is is really
important and just leaving it to people
what do we do right now for the vast
majority of people we just say well
you'll kind of figure it out as you go
but then when you make mistakes
and you damage your credit it can be
very hard to recover from that and then
that then your interest rates are higher
and then it makes it more likely that
you're going to run into financial
problems so i think we'd all be better
off if people had the basic skills they
needed at the front end so they don't
have to kind of learn by making mistakes
yeah completely completely agree and you
know we're happy to we should figure out
how we can work together to to to make
that make that a reality you know
another a great question from youtube
christina espinoza
what advice do you have for teenagers
who saw the gamestop event and want to
take advantage of stock slash investing
what do children need to know so
i have an opinion there as well i know
you are a former investment banker i
used to work as an analyst at a hedge
fund so i definitely have a point of
view but yeah what would you tell
christina uh about well i'm just curious
what's your point of view on the whole
event is that you think this is just
gonna pass us by or do you think this
will lead to
some form of structural change in some
way uh and then what advice would you
have for teenagers who are looking to to
to get into finance or invest
well i think what you're seeing in the
markets with these individual stocks
like gamestock i would just call it
gamble it's one group of speculators
that's battling another group of
speculators in a test of wills and my
basic view on that is that's their right
god bless them let them do what they
want and if they if they make money
terrific if they lose money that's their
fault and that's on them and nobody
needs to take care of them for that so
they need to go into it eyes wide open
but to the to the teenager asking the
question
that's gambling it is rolling the dice
and when you go to vegas and i used to
go to vegas when i was a lot younger
you go to vegas with
some money in your pocket you got to be
prepared to walk away and lose it all
because that's what that is very
possibly what could happen if you're
serious about getting into investing you
should study it you should take some
classes go to go to college or community
college take some finance classes some
banking classes and you can learn about
how financial markets work so that
you're not just blindly so that you're
not just blindly gambling what we're
seeing right now is just gambling in the
markets and it might work out for some
it's not going to work out for most
people
yep and i i just want to i just want to
add 100 agree with everything you just
said uh you know as someone who used to
work in the investment world i can tell
you that you know when when it comes to
individual stock picking there's many
very smart people who are doing a lot of
research and still is a very hard job
and you know i remember my old boss used
to tell me
anytime you think you have a good
investment idea when you're buying a
stock someone else is selling that stock
to you so you've got to believe that you
you know something that they don't uh
and you know when and i do encourage
anyone of any age but especially young
people you know put some small amount of
money into the stock market if you can
and you will learn this lesson
that the market uh is is a lot harder
and the other people on the side of the
trade um are probably more sophisticated
than than you you might guess and so
completely neo that it is
very speculative now there could be
something about accumulating capital
having a diversified portfolio over time
that that could be something to to look
into or if you want to become a
professional as an investment manager
yeah do your research and and and do
your homework and learn to invest the
right way not not just speculation but
but yeah
so for example i don't own any
individual stocks
i own i own index funds so i do have
exposure to the stock market and the
bond market but i'm not sitting here
saying i'd have to spend my whole day
and night trying to do research to
compete with the professionals who are
literally spending all day and all night
doing that research
yeah i mean i'll just add to that i used
to my day job for seven years was an
analyst at a hedge fund where all we did
is essentially pick stocks and uh to
like you my 401k i have it in some
diversified mutual funds but i own no
individual stocks right now either all
of our all of our savings i bought some
rental properties that's that's my
that's my so i i completely agree with
you it's a very it's a very hard game to
pick um individual individual individual
stocks for things like that um you know
one question that i i like to ask
guests because you know we could talk
about the economy all day and i have a
ton of questions there but also just
want to understand your personal journey
to how you got there because i don't
think you know
i'm guessing when you were 15 years old
you didn't say oh my career is going to
be i'm going to be president of the
federal reserve bank of minneapolis so
and i know there's a lot of young people
who are constantly like what should i do
with my life how do i have an impact
what you know so what was your journey
like what did you think you were going
to be when you were a teenager and then
how did that evolve how did you end up
where you are
well i started out my i went to college
and i studied mechanical engineering at
the university of illinois and the
reason i went to engineering school is
because
as a kid i always loved math and science
and physics and building things so
engineering seemed like an obvious place
for me to go i did my bachelor's in
masters in engineering then i went into
aerospace and started developing
technology for nasa i went there because
to me working on nasa's space missions
was as exciting as challenging as it
could be and so i learned a ton and i
loved it but i also realized you know my
managers wanted me to get my phd in
which case i'd really be committing to a
career in research i wasn't ready to do
that so i decided to go back to business
school to learn about business and
finance that led me to banking then i
went to the u.s treasury department and
i've had a lot of twists and turns the
one common thread for me is i always
pursue things i'm really interested in
that i think are important that i think
are challenging and if i'm really
challenged and i'm interested i'll end
up doing my best and that'll lead to
hopefully lead me to be successful and
that's been true so far so there's been
no plan
i've done a variety of different things
the longest job i've ever had is now
here at the minneapolis fed for five
years and i'm excited i just got
reappointed so i'll be staying
staying around which i'm excited about
but i guess my message is pursue things
you're genuinely interested in and life
is wrong you know your first job does
not have to be your last job sal as you
said you were an analyst at a hedge fund
for seven years i bet along the way you
never dreamt that you'd be running this
you know world-renowned non-profit
educating millions of people around the
world
i had a lot of daydreams
some of which came true
some of some my my
yeah i still have my whole singer
songwriter folk music career has still
not gotten off the ground so you know
it's all it's all one platform uh on on
on on on to the next but yeah i couldn't
agree more with that narrative you know
i am curious
and this might be part of your distant
memory now but you definitely came first
on my radar back in 2010 when it looked
like the financial system was kind of
seizing in some way
you were you were working for um
secretary of treasury hank paulson at
the time to really think about how to un
unstick the economy is the best way i
could interpret it but but i i do have
to say you know what when it was
happening as as much as i wanted the
economy to get unstuck i was also like
wow there's a lot of actors who did a
lot of things that were
shady you know you had the ratings
agencies that were approving you know
putting a a high rating on you know
sliced and diced securities that uh were
questionable in value and you had all
these incentives and you know i think
most of us who even though i i now run a
not-for-profit and you run a
semi-quasi-independent government
institution um i i would say we both
arguably believe in free markets and you
know part of the best corrective force
on free markets is kind of uh you know
what you you deal with the consequences
of your actions uh and so you know back
in 2010 when a lot of these banks were
kind of at the cusp of
failing because they'd argue had we had
taken on more risk than they shouldn't
uh you know how how did y'all think
about that you know i used to say yeah i
get you need to keep the banks kind of
going so the economy doesn't seize uh
but what if you were to you know take
the shares and you know kind of go
through a controlled bankruptcy process
and distribute them to the people of
america so it stays private uh what were
the conversations back then around stuff
like that
yeah we had those conversations and it
was terrifying and the fear that we had
was that if the banking system collapsed
and you'd have that you'd have that
justice moment you know shareholders get
wiped out the banks would collapse
people said it's like a forest fire let
the fire rage and then the next season
new saplings emerge and what i always
point out is that may be true but then
all the animals are dead
and so what are the consequences to the
american people who did not cause the
banking crisis
if the u.s banking system were allowed
to collapse you know in the great
depression we had 25 unemployment in the
great recession
even though we did all of this massive
intervention treasury congress the fed
we still had 10 unemployment so it was
still a devastating crisis and so i
think i don't think letting it all fail
was a reasonable thing to do because the
cost would have been borne by the
american people not just those on wall
street having said that you know i've
been a strong advocate since i joined
the minneapolis fed that we need to do a
lot more to make sure that can never
happen again and we need we need much
stronger regulations on the biggest
banks so that they don't have risk of
bringing down the u.s economy again and
we have not done enough yet
no i i've actually come around to that
back in 2009 2010 i was i had a much
more principled view that like you know
what you know deal with the consequences
or control the consequences and and
figure out something that you know on a
principal level but i think you're right
you know history has shown that what
could have led us into the next great
depression uh those 10 years were
actually a a period of actually quite
good economic growth uh that you know
frankly if kova didn't happen we would
have still been on that curve that
started back in 2010 so and and i so
i've come around uh to to uh the fact
that i think y'all probably did save the
economy
in in that time frame and and and
honestly the the country owes y'all for
that uh because i can imagine
what what it's been through you know
just in the remaining time that we have
i just kind of open it up to you you
know any advice you have for folks
on you know they're they're dealing
they're trying to form a view on the
economy on the world or just on what to
do with their life where we have people
of all ages watching us right now uh
what what what advice would you have
well first thing
get vaccinated as soon as you're
eligible i know as soon as my turn is it
comes uh i'm 47 years old i'm not quite
not going to get a vaccine for a couple
more months but as soon as it's
available i'm going to get vaccinated
the best thing we can do to get our
economy reopened is to vaccinate the
vast majority of americans starting with
those who are highest risk but everybody
else matters too because we could still
get sick when we could still spread the
virus and so that's so important for the
economic recovery my mom has been
vaccinated my sister my cousins their
doctors they've been vaccinated uh you
know i'm waiting for my turn so that's
number one number two
and i just applaud you for tuning in to
this uh to this video call or this
podcast
education is so important it's been so
important in my life and my success and
in our economy uh education is only
becoming more important it's important
to get continue to improve your skills
continue to get new skills and so keep
investing in yourself to get more skills
and more education
education is the key to unlocking
opportunity in our country it is the
best tool we have to equalize our
society and we know it and the reason
i'm so passionate about education if
people get a good education it's the
most powerful tool we have to break the
cycle of poverty and so sal i really
applaud what you and your colleagues at
the khan academy are doing and i would
just encourage encourage all of your
viewers
to you know be part of that process
invest in themselves invest in their
families and the whole country will be
better off for it
no well i couldn't agree more on both
the vaccination and the education side
of things uh and in my household my wife
is a physician so she got vaccinated my
mother-in-law who's at risk uh needs her
second dose but i'm i'm i'm i'm now the
the the missing link uh but i completely
agree with that and and and neil thank
you so much for joining us uh our you
know so many questions of have been
coming in i apologize for not being able
to get to a lot of them for everyone
watching uh but this was a real treat
not only to understand the economy a
little bit better uh but also to
understand your life journey and i think
it gives everyone confidence uh that you
know there's some there's some really
good people trying to do good for the
world in in our in our government and
our financial system so so thank you so
much
thank you sal this is a lot of fun i
appreciate it
thanks
so thank you everyone for joining
hopefully you enjoyed that conversation
and i do encourage you there was a lot
of questions that came in is one from
adrian
hamroccio talking about how to how to uh
where to invest money and things like
that we actually do have a lot of
content on khan academy on both personal
finance actually on and on finance and
capital markets generally so if you're a
young person or if you're the parent of
a young person watch that stuff together
because frankly a lot of adults most
adults don't understand exactly how all
of that works and so once you understand
that i'd also recommend uh you know you
can get stock simulators a lot of people
are asking how to learn about stock
investing and things like that you can
play with fake money initially and and
see how you can perform uh but if you
have some money saved up five hundred
dollars a thousand dollars that could be
a really good education to kind of see
to start learning about investing and
putting it to work and seeing what works
and what doesn't work
i think is a good way to start learning
about about money
but anyway i'll i'll stop there this is
going to be our only live stream for
this week we're going to get a little
bit more regular over the weeks to come
i know we've had a few hiatuses i don't
know is that the plural of hiatus hiatai
uh
but i will see y'all uh next week so see
y'all soon thanks for joining us
you